23 years ago at the age of 19 I shot and
killed a man I was a young drug dealer
with a quick temper and a semi-automatic
pistol but that wasn't the end of my
story in fact it was the beginning in
the 23 years since there's a story of
acknowledgement apology and atonement
but it didn't happen in the way that you
might imagine or think these things
occurred in my life in the way that was
surprising especially to me see like any
of you growing up I was an honor roll
student scholarship student but dreams
of becoming a doctor but things went
dramatically wrong my parents separated
and eventually divorced the actual
events are pretty straightforward at the
age of 17 I got shot three times
stunned on the corner of my block in
Detroit my friend rushed me to the
hospital doctors pulled the bullets out
hats me up and send me back to the same
neighborhood I got shot throughout this
ordeal
no one hugged me no one counseled me no
one told me I would be okay no one told
me that I would live in fear that I will
become paranoid but that I would react
hyper violently to being shot no one
told me that one day I would become the
person behind the trigger 14 months
later
at 2:00 a.m. I fired the shots that
caused the man's death when I answered
prison I was bitter I was angry I was
hurt I didn't want to take
responsibility I blamed everybody for my
parents to the system
I rest in lies my decision to shoot
because in the hood where I come from
it's better be the shooter than the
person getting shot as I said in my cold
cell I felt helpless unloved and
abandoned I felt like nobody cared and I
reacted with hostility to my confinement
and I found myself getting deeper in the
deeper in trouble
I ran black market stores a loan sharks
and I saw drugs that was legally
smuggled into the prison I had in fact
become what the war done a Miskin
reformatory called the worst of the
worse and because of my activity I
landed in solitary confinement for seven
and a half years out of my incarceration
now as I see a solitary confinement is
one of the most inhumane and barbaric
places you can find yourself well find
myself I did one day was pacing myself
when the officer came and delivered mail
I looked at a couple of letters before I
looked at the letter that had my son's
Quigley handwriting on it and any time I
would get this letter from my son it was
like a ray of light in the darkest place
you can imagine and on this particular
day I opened this letter and in capital
letters he wrote my momma told me why he
was in prison murder
said dad don't kill Jesus watches what
you do pray to Him now I wasn't
religious at that time normal religious
now but it was something so profound
about my son's words they made me
examine things about my life that I
hadn't considered it was the first time
in my life that I had actually thought
about the fact that my son would see me
as a murderer I sat back on my bunk and
I reflected on something I had read in
Plato's Republic where Socrates stated
an apology that the unexamined life
isn't worth living at that point is when
the transformation began but it didn't
come easy
one of the things I realized was part of
the transformation is that there are
four key things the first thing was I
had great mentors now I know some of
y'all probably thinking like how do you
find a great mentor in prison but in my
case some of my mentors were serving
life sentences were some of the best
people to ever come into my life because
they forced me to look at my life
honestly and they forced me to challenge
myself about my decision-making the
second thing was literature prior to
going to prison I didn't know that there
were so many brilliant black poets
authors and philosophers and then I had
the great fortune of encountering
Malcolm X's autobiography and it
shattered every stereotype I had about
myself the third thing was family for 19
years my father stood by my side with an
unshakable faith because he believed it
I had what it took to turn my life
around I also met an amazing woman who
was not a mother my two-year-old son say
cool she taught me how to love myself in
a healthy way
the final thing was writing when I got
that letter for my son I began to write
a journal about things I had experienced
in my childhood and in prison and what
it did is it opened up my mind to the
idea of atonement earlier in my
incarceration I received a letter from
one of the relatives of my victim and in
that letter she told me she forgave me
because she realized I was a young child
who had been abused and I've been
through some hardships and just made a
series of poor decisions
it was the first time in my life that I
ever felt open to forgiving myself one
of the things that happened after that
experience is that I thought about the
other men who were incarcerated long
side of me and how much I wanted to
share this with them and so I started
talking to them about some of their
experiences and I was devastated to
realize that most of them came from the
same abusive environments and most of
them wanted to help and they wanted to
turn that around
but unfortunately the system that
currently holds 2.5 million people in
prison is designed a warehouse as
opposed to rehabilitate or transformed
so I made it up in my mind that if I was
ever released from prison that I would
do everything in my power to help change
that 2010 I walked out of prison for the
first time after two decades now imagine
if you will Fred Flintstone
walking into an episode of the Jetsons
that was pretty much what my life was
like for the first time I was exposed to
the internet social media cars that
talked like hit from the Nightrider but
the thing that fascinated me the most
was phone technology see when I went to
prison our car phones was this big and
cry like two people to carry him so
imagine what it was like when I first
grabbed my little blackberry and I
started learning how to text but the
thing is the people around me they
didn't realize that I had no idea what
all these abbreviated sex men like lol
oMG lmao until one day I was having a
conversation with one of my friends via
text and I asked him to do something he
responded back cake and I was like what
is K and he was like k is okay so in my
head I was like well what's the hell is
wrong okay
and so I take some a question mark and
he said K equals okay it's luck setback
fu and then he checks back and he asked
me what was our custom amount and I said
lol fu as in I finally understand and so
fast for three years I'm doing
relatively good I have a fellowship at
MIT Media Lab I work for an amazing
company called beat me I teach at the
University of Michigan but it's been a
struggle because I realized that there
are more men and women coming home who
are not going to be afforded those
opportunities I've been blessed to work
with some amazing men and women helping
others reenter society one of them is my
friend named Calvin Evans he started to
serve 24 years for crime he didn't
commit
45 years old it's currently enrolled in
college
and one of the things that we talked
about is the three things that I found
important of my personal transformation
the first being acknowledgment
I had the knowledge that I had heard of
us I also had the knowledge that I had
been hurt the second thing was
apologizing I had to apologize to the
people I hurt even though I had no
expectations of them accepting it it was
important to do because it was the right
thing but also had the pologize to
myself the third thing was atoning for
me atoning meant going back it's from
our community and working with at-risk
youth who were on the same path but also
becoming that one with myself through my
experience being locked up one of the
things I discovered is this the majority
of men and women who are incarcerated
are redeemable and the fact is 90% of
the men and women were incarcerated but
at some point returned to the community
and we have a role in determining what
kind of men and women return to our
community my wish today is that we will
embrace a more empathetic approach to
how we deal with mass incarceration
that we would do away with the lock them
up and throw away to keep mentality
because it's proven it doesn't work my
journey is a unique journey but it
doesn't have to be that way anybody can
have transformation if we create the
space for that to happen so what I'm
asking today is that to envision a world
where men and women aren't held hostage
to their past where misdeeds and
mistakes doesn't define you for the rest
of your life I think collectively we can
create that reality and I hope you do
too
thank you
[Applause]